معلقاتنا امتداد امجاد مسرحيه شعريه
غنائيه هي الاولى من نوعها في السعوديه
احتفالا بيوم التاسيس وتر جديد مفاجئ في
سوق الهواتف عوده قويه للهواتف الغبيه هو
جونسون بيقول بوتن هددوا بصاروخ والكريم
بيرد كذب وما حصل اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نظمت امس هيئه المسرح والفنون الادائيه في
السعوديه مؤتمر صحفي تم الكشف في عن
تفاصيل العرض المسرحي الغنائي الاول من
نوعه معلقاتنا امتداد امجاد وهو العمل
اللي بيؤرخ لامجاد المملكه في تسعه عروض
يوم التاسيس اللي بتحتفل في المملكه في 22
فبراير المقبل ان شاء الله المؤتمر تم
بحضور الامير عبد الرحمن بن مساعد صاحب
الفكره والمشرف العام على المشروع اللي
قال ان فكره العمل جاءت له من سنتين
وبتلخص فكرتها بمجارات المعلقات وكتابه 10
معلقات جديده وطلب من 10 من اصحابه
الشعراء انهم يساعدوا في المشروع وحضر
المؤتمر ايضا صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
احمد بن سلطان بن عبد العزيز ورئيس
التنفيذي الهيئه السلطان البازعي ونائب
المشرف العام المخرج عامر الحمود
مؤتمر كان مليان بالقطات اللي الناس وقفت
عندها
وتداولتها وابرزها كلام لافت جدا عن
الملحن صادق الشاعر
انه احنا بدينا بالحوارات اللي تمهد
للمعلقات
موسيقي فهد عفت وصادق الشاعر
عشان ما حد يسالني عن صادق الشاعر صادق
الشاعر في المسرحيه هذه انا بس غير هلا
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
يعني هو اعطاني دور في المسرح
الامير احمد بن سلطان او سهم كان له تصريح
كمان من المؤتمر تم تداوله بشكل واسع
صدقني
لما تسمع اصوات الاساتذه اللي هناك
انا كموسيقى استحي الحقيقه احط صوتي جنبه
هذا واحد
اثنين
الشغف اللي عند العبد لله
ما هو ان صوته اللي يبان شغف اللي عندي
لاصوات
جميله
تطلب المتلقي فعلا هذا هذا هو شغف الواحد
ولذلك قلتها من قبل مراره تكرار انا
الشغف اللي عندي هو التاليف الموسيقي وليس
الاداء
وشكرا على الاطراء يعني لكن ما هو والله
شغل
الهاتف الامير الشاعر عبد الرحمن بن مساعد
صاحب فكره العمل والمشرف علاء اهلا فيك
معانا سمو الامير والشيخ خليني اقول لك
مبروك لانه احنا تكلمنا سابقا عن هذا
المشروع واعرف قد ايش يعني لك يعني
اتفائل بمداخلات معك اعاده ان يعقوب وانا
نجاحات
احرز على اي مداخله اكون معك
مهم جدا مهم جدا يارب
فعمل مهم في غايه الاهميه مثل ما تفضلتي
هو عمل جماعي ما في بطل واحد يعني في
ابطال الكسر
والعمل هو البطل وامل الحقيقه انا ما ابغى
احرقه على الناس انا قلت بعض
الاشياء الصحفي ولكن نحن امام مسرحيه
شعريه غنائيه
لاول مره في المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
الخليج بها المستوى الاحترافي العالي
الحقيقه كمان ابغى
اقول يعني ما كان ممكن العمل هذا يتم لون
المناخ الفني
والدعم اللي موجود في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
للثقافه والفنون والسياحه والرياضه جميع
العناصر القوه الناعمه الان في دعم كبير
لها من الدوله وفق رؤيه ولي العهد الله
وجميع قطاعات الدوله تنفذ هذه الرؤيه
باحسن طريقه ممكنه ولا شيء الى مثله انا
من خلال وزاره الثقافه لكن الامكانيات انه
عمل بهالحجم وبهل مجهود اللي انعمل فيه
يتناسب مع يكون معه عرض يوازي ما بذل فيه
من جهد هذا ما كان ممكن الامكانيات لي
وفرت لنا من وزاره الثقافه ولولا الرؤيا
لولي العهد في كل المجلات انا اعتقد انه
ال- ال- الفنانين والمبدعين هم اقدروا
الناس على التعبير عن حضاره بلدهم
والفنون والثقافه بشكل عام هي المجال
الاكثر قدره على توصيل حضاره اي بلد
واعطاء فكره حقيقيه
ايش تقصده بهذا الشيء تحديدا
انه انت لما نحنا طبعا عشان تكوني في
الصوره المسج حق العمل او الرساله حق
العمل انه
هي مهبط الوحي هي يعني ارض اللغه العربيه
جميع شعراء المعلقات اللي من 16 قرن كلهم
بدون استثناء الشعراء العشره عاشوا في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بلوى وصفوا في
معلقاتهم التي خلدت والتي قال كثير من
المؤرخون انها علقت على الكعبه الشريفه
بمكه المكرمه
كلهم وصفوا في معلقاتهم مناطق المملكه من
شمال شرقها ومن غربها الجنوب ما في احد
يستطيع ما في دوله تستطيع ان تنسب الى
ترابها
الحضاري المعلقات العربيه وهي شيخ خالد ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لهذا السبب
فالحقيقه ان نحنا مهبط الوحيله لان احنا
موطن اللغه العربيه احنا الكتاب امتدادنا
ما هو 300 بس احنا امتدادنا 16 قرن ربطنا
المعلقات وجارناها واسقطناها
وثيقه تاريخيه
وعوجت بشكل ازعم انه كان موفق وان شاء
الله يعني طبعا ما اقدر امدح العمل ولكن
انا متاكد انه نحن بذلنا فيك اقصى ما
نستطيع من جهد وكل اللي عمله فيه للامانه
قدموا افضل ما لديهم اتمنى انه هذا ينتج
عنه عمل يرضي المتنقل انا شايف انه بعض
الناس جالسين بيسموه اوبريت وانت مو عاجبك
كثير الموضوع اسمه لا لا لا احنا ابعد ما
نكون عنبر
استخدام اوبريت في وصفه
انه تعرفين في فرق بين المسرح الشعري
الغنائي وبين العبوديه اللي هيجي يتفرج
على العرض من يوم 19 فبراير الى اليوم 28
سييدرك اننا امام مسرحيه شعريه غنائيه
ونحن امام مطريه ما في شيء بالعكس وبريتات
جميله
ولاقت نجاحات وستلاقى لوبريتات القادمه بس
احنا هنا
هيبان للناس ليش اسمها مسرحيه شعريه
لانه فيها تمثيل فيها فيها فيها
مشاهد تمثيليه فيها حوارات فيها المسرح
اللي همم صالح زمان
ساعدنا بفكره انه انه انه نخرج شعراء
المعلقات ليكونوا معنا على المسرح بطريقه
مبتكره هيشوفونها الناس في العرض فاحنا ما
ما مش بس وفيها حوار شعري غنائي فيها يعني
موضوع من ناحيه الطرح اكاد اجزم انه غير
مسبوق
جميل جدا واحده من الاشياء اللي كانت
لابسه في المؤتمر الصحفي سمو قلت انا في
هذا العمل صادق الشاعر بس بس في هذه العمل
كيف وحيد يقدر يعني يكون في عمل واحد صادق
الشاعر يعني طبعا صادق الشاعر اللي هو
الملحن المعروف
ساره انت انت الموضوع هذا
وتحققين معايا
واحد طب انا بس والله العظيم عندي بالسؤال
يعني واحد عامل البرواز ملحد البرواز ملحن
شبيه الريح ملحن هذه الاعمال الضخمه كلها
ما يبغى يقول انا هذا الملحن والله شوفي
بقول لك على شيء انا ما ابغى
يعني العبد لله كشاعر
ب بشيء اخر فعشان كذا ملاحظ ص
ادق الشصادق الشاعر حلوه الاجابه هذه
انا تعبانه
خلاص والله العظيم
حرام
ههه بس الا اذا اخذناها ان السكوت علامه
الرضا
[ضحك]
الحقيقه
يعني ابغى اشيل الحاجه تمام
والله
والله يا ساره من غير مبالغه انا انه
اسمحي لي اقول لك ساره انك غاليه استاذ
استاذه واعلاميه قصير ابدا دائما قولي
ساره والله العظيم العمل هذا انا من
الاعمال اللي فعلا فخور فيها الى درجه
يعني صعب تخيلها وصعب وافر يعني واتمنى
انه التوفيق يد رب العالمين وما له قتلوه
ولكن يا رب على قد الجهد اللي عملناه لان
احنا شغالين فعلا في العمل هذا من سنتين
المختلفه جدا الاسامي اللي مختارينا في
العمل احنا متعودين على اسامي معينه كبيره
دائما موجوده انتم رحتوا في اتجاه الثاني
مختلف تماما بالضبط بالضبط احنا تعمدنا
ذلك طبعا الفنانين كبار يعني عشان اكون
امين احنا احنا وزاره الثقافه كانت دعمتنا
يعني وفقوا رؤيه سيدي ولي العهد لدعم
الثقافه والفنون بشكل عام بان نحنا قادرين
كنا نحنا يعني نستخطب الفنانين الكبار
والفنانين الصف الاول حتى من نادي
ولكن يعني طبعا لو كانوا جوف الفضيلنا
فنانين الصف الاول بالتاكيد كانوا اضافه
عظيمه للامل هم من هم ويكفي ما قدموه ولكن
احنا تعمدنا انه المشروع تكون يعني ما فيه
يكون هو البطل مثل لانه انا مثلا لما لما
جات الف في البدايه جبت عشر
شهور ازعم اني استطيع ان يعني انا قادر
اني اكتب النصوص كلها الحقيقه ما كنت
هكتبها بروعه اللي كتبوه الاخوان الشعر
اللي اللي وصلت لهم المهمه
يعني صادق الشاعر ايضا قادر انه يلحن
الموضوع كله بس كان موجود سهم ضروري جدا
يعطي الجانب الاغنيه يعني سهم عنده قدره
انه يعمل اغنيه تضرب موسيقيه عاليه لابد
من وجوده الفنانين الشباب اللي اخترناهم
عندهم شغف غير
بدنا من الاسبوع قاعدين نسوي بروفات يعني
جروبات اللي سواها الفنانين اللي شغالين
معنا اربعه اسابيع وراء بعض
هم فالشغب هذا كنا نحتاجه وبنفس الوقت
كمان رؤيه سيدي ولي العهد قائمه على
الشباب بس واستخدام الشباب يعني ولقيتها
فرصه مناسبه يعتبر نفسي من الشباب
اشكرك على وجودك معي دائما بتكون اضافه
وبتنورني وان شاء الله دائما وجهي يكون
حلو علاج زي وجهك حلو علي يعني وان شاء
الله
في العربيه اولا في برنامج
اعلاميه قديره ومختلفه الكهرباء
يجيك الستديو المره الجايه ابشر يا سلام
تنورنا خلاص اوكي
تسلم كل الشكر وكل التوفيق يا رب ان شاء
الله
كان معنا الامير الشاعر عبد الرحمن بن
مساعد صاحب فكره العمل والمشرف عليه
[موسيقى]
من بعد كل التطور الي بنعيشه في كل
النواحي وخاصه في التكنولوجيا والهواتف
الذكيه من كان يتخيل انه في يوم من الايام
رح ترجع على الهواتف الغبيه الى الوجه
لا كمان تصير ترند في كل العالم
الجيل الجديد اللي ما يعرف الا الهواتف
الذكيه او انه يعني التاتش سكرين والمتاجر
الالكترونيه اللي مليانه بالتطبيقات هم
جزء اساسي من هذا التراند وبيبدل
تليفوناتهم ذكيه بالتليفونات قديمه
ومميزات اقل وشركه نوكيا اللي يوم من
الايام كانت الرقم واحد في بيعه
التليفونات اذا تتذكروا في مرحله ما قبل
ما تخرج منها البساط تليفونات الاندرويد
والايفون نوكيا كشف الاسبوع الماضي انهم
راجعين للسوق وبقوه انه السنه الماضيه
استعاده جزء كبير من وجودهم في السوق طيب
اللي بتسال طيب ايش السبب اللي خلى
الهواتف القديمه ترجع تتصدر الاسباب كثيره
لكن كلها بتدور في فلك واحد وهو الضغط
بتعملوا علينا هذه التليفونات والتطبيقات
اللي عليها سواء منصات التواصل تطبيقات
الاخبار الالعاب تطبيقات المراسله الفوريه
طبعا الواتساب وغيره وغيره طبعا من الامور
في الواحد صاير طول الوقت فعليا يبقى يعرف
كل شيء وما يبغى يفوتوا اي شيء هذا غير
متابعه الاخبار اللي بتزيد عن حدها اوقات
ومنصات التواصل اللي معاها كمان بتزيد
المقارنه مع الاخرين واحساس الواحد انه
الثانيين احسن منه فالناس بدات الترم هذه
التليفونات باللي فيها وترجع لتليفونات
بتتصل وتبعث رسائل نصيه بسيطه وفيها كم
لعبه بدائيه وشكرا ما تبغى اي شيء اضافي
خلاص تفضل خلينا نتكلم شويه عن هذا
الموضوع او نحاول نفهمه معنا من الرياضيات
صانع المحتوى التقني فيصل السيف اهلا فيك
معنا همم فيصل لاي درجه فعلا يعني واصل
الوضع انه نرجع لها التليفون يعني
يا اهلا وسهلا فيك مساكم الله بالخير جميع
الوضع صار صعب في بعض المناطق بعض الدول
وايضا مع بعض الافراد فعشان كده المغرب
الوحيد يمكن اما اخذ قسط من الراحه من
الجوالات الذكيه والانتقال لهذه الجوالات
اللي انت سميتها غبيه
يعني غبيه اللي بنستعمله اليوم
اتحسنت تطورت عمرها ومن ريحه البطاريه
والشاشه والى الحين للتوضيح ترى الجوالات
الاقتصاديه اللي من هذا النوع يعمل اكثر
انتشارا في العالم بالذات لاتكلمنا عن بعض
الدول لماذا زالت البنيه التحتيه في
الاتصالات حقتهم القوه فبالتالي ما يعتمد
على الانترنت
الذكيه بشكل مستمر هذه الجوالات ما هرب
ممتاز للحصول على جواد تستخدم
راجعين اخذين حصه من السوق تعتقد بسبب هذا
الموضوع تحديدا
اولا نتوقع ان الموضوع كمان لم نوكيا
قالوا كانه في جانب تسويق نوكيا ليست بحجم
الماضي ابدا ابدا ما هي زي زمان فبالتالي
ما لهم الحصه السوقيه الضخمه الحصه
السوقيه ابخن عن شركات اخرى هم لما يقولوا
بدات تتحسن هذه النتائج عندنا من ناحيه
المبيعات فما قاعدين نتكلم على معرض
الصغير موجود عندهم في السوق شيء يمكن
يقدروا من خلاله نحاولوا يجيبوا زخم
الاعلام بشكل قوي وايضا نظيفه الى ذلك
انهم قطع نفسه بحد ذاته ما هو بيعتبر لا
مليار له ملياري ولا اكثر من كده من ناحيه
الوسط فبالتالي بتلاقي دائما حتى عندنا في
الخليج في المناطق العربيه هذا الجوال هل
ثانوي حسن جدا ممتاز انه دائما معه الناس
اللي حولنا قدام اللي عندهم اعمال يوميا
بشكل مستمر اعمال صعبه هذا الجوال هو
المهرب اللي استخدمه خلال العمل والجوالات
الذكيه هذه خلوها في البيت
اللي شايله فعلا جوال يعني بس كده يت
ويستقبل طيب الان اا بيقولوا الناس كمان
في ترن ثاني انهم رجعوا لهذه التليفونات
لانه كاميراتها ما هي بجوده الكاميرات
الجديده في الصور بتطلع كانها مفلتره ما
تحسنت الكاميرات
تحسنت الكاميرون
حكم السعر حقها فطبيع الحال لما تدفع سعر
عالي 1000 ريال وفوق هتلاقي انه قطع نفسها
المستخدمه هتعطي جوده افضل بكثير من هذه
الجوالات بيننا نقول نعم تحسنت تطورت ولكن
ما زالت تعتبر جدا بدائيه ليش لانه ما
فيها تطبيقات ونظام تشغيل منتشر زي اللي
احنا عارفين اذا ما في تطبيق
زوجته
لانه كل الاشياء اللي انت بتتكلم عنها هذه
اشياء اساسيه يعني همم جوجل مابس لو انا
ضايعه لو بدي ادخل مثلا من البنك اشياء زي
كده يعني هقدر حتى لو بدي صحه النفسيه
تتحسن
النفسيه تتحسن حبي نمط الطيران شويه
وبعدين ارجعي بشغل الجوال
اللي كان موجود الرسائل الثانيه اللي
حطينا نقطه
طيران
[ضحك]
من كفاءه التطبيقات وتصير التطبيقتا يتحمل
اكثر شويه فبالتالي هتلاقي نفسك مليت من
الجواره
النوم هذا لانه اصلا يعني عشان اوصل اقنع
نفسي اني اسوي كده يعني هذه مرحله متقدمه
على العموم شكرا لك
فيصل شكرا لك
اهلا من جديد
من ثلاث اجزاء راح يتم عرضه اليوم على بي
بي سي وبروم الفيلم
انطلاق الحرب في اوكرانيا ام اي تهديد
تهديد بصاروخ
ان
برج جونسون قال كمان انه بوتن كان هادي
كثير وكان كانه بيحاول يجاريه في محاولاته
للتفاوض الروسيجا على هذا الكلام على
السريع جاء وعلى لسان المتحدث باسم الكريم
اللي وسط التصريحات كلها بالكذب
مشاهدين احنا وصلنا الى الختام حلقه اليوم
دائما تابعوا فيديوهاتنا واخبارنا على
حساباتنا على
السوشيال ميديا وطبعا سنعود من القاكم في
حلقه جديده ان شاء الله غدا ومواضع جديده
في تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]